speaking of narcissistic
self-glamorizing
etc people uh barack obama was back at
the white house this week uh with
michelle and they had their white house
portraits unveiled and
hilariously uh barack thinks things are
going pretty well right now because of
old joe all did together
to expand health care to fight climate
change
to advance social justice
and to promote economic fairness thanks
to your decency and thanks to your
strength
maybe most of all thanks to your faith
in our democracy and the american people
the country's better off than when you
took office and we should all be deeply
grateful for that so thank you so much
robert can you uh lay out a couple
reasons that maybe the country isn't
better off right now than it was under
donald trump
well i mean that's ordinary americans
complete expectations is that the
economy has tanked that our society is
in disarray we have a complete debacle
in afghanistan we have a ongoing war
that may lead to world war iii in both
ukraine and taiwan so most people don't
consider massive scandal explosive risk
of war and a completely collapsing
economy is a sign of a president who's
done a good job
is the key there to the obama thing what
you know okay so he says climate change
and health care but the key really was
the third thing when he says social
justice that that really is what has
driven this entire administration they
have hired a series of completely
incompetent people based on skin color
or gender or sexual identity and
everything else but that really that's
what what is driving this whole thing
and maybe it's really obama behind this
because obviously joe ain't driving the
car
you know he's had a few too many trips
to the white house obama he's been
keeping it very close and with this
candidacy and with this with this
president and like i say david it's
never been a better time to be me in
america i could be working in the white
house right now with absolutely no
qualifications and what robert said is
right you know you can call joe biden a
fantastic president and say that he's
doing amazing things for this country
but when people walk out their front
door and see the state of their
communities they're going to know that
that is not the case no matter how
charismatic obama is so okay i get all
four of us people can look at these four
boxes and go okay wait a minute you guys
aren't democrats you don't like these
people this this is too easy so spencer
i'm going to give you the hardest
question of the day which is let's try
to give the devil his due here has biden
done anything good is anything being
done right is is are we just really
missing something are we all being hyper
partisan is there anything here that
this man i mean that speech can you get
anything out of that great nazi speech i
mean is there anything let's try here
well what you really have to give him
credit for of course is that he did
lower the temperature you know of our
politics he brought us back to normalcy
exactly as he promised this was the
premise of his entire campaign is that
he was going to be not trump and i think
we can all agree that he's not trump
trump presided over a great economy he
managed a lot of excellent trade deals
he broke her to you know step toward
peace in the middle east
none of that is happening under under
biden so he has delivered on his promise
of being not trump i i also think that
it makes perfect sense that obama you
know thinks
uh thinks things are going great under
biden because he's probably closer to
running the country under biden than
biden himself is i mean that's one thing
we could say
biden may have done well is is uh be
incompetent or be ineffectual you know
so much of his uh so many of his efforts
have fallen flat especially in in
congress and the overreach that we've
seen come out of this democrat party not
just biden but the
legislators they've elected has been a
gift to the country in the sense that
we've seen the kind of extremism that
lurks underneath the sort of friendly
uncle joe returned to normalcy
you tried man you really i did my best